[Applause]
Treyarch zombies is the one that started
it all and the beloved mode has evolved
a lot over the years games and Call of
Duty developers for black ops 3 zombies
chronicles remasters 8 maps from world
at war through black ops 2 it's a
greatest hits collection with enough
variety to bring in new and veteran
zombies players alike and it makes it
worth revisiting zombies at its roots
you created those abominations
chronicles has a strong foundation in
its map selection it includes smaller
more manageable Maps like World Wars
Nocturne totin alongside more complex
story centric maps like black ops
ascension if you're new to zombies you
can hone strategies on the simpler Maps
if you've been a fan of Treyarch zombies
for a while at least one of your
favorites is here there's also a good
variety in map structure and the
strategies they each call for from the
more open shi no numa to the small
easily overrun rooms of route these maps
are now better than ever thanks to the
fantastic technical improvements
atmospheric enhancements from eerie
screeches to subtle lighting changes
supplement the more straightforward
graphics upgrade and they make the same
gripping stay up all night zombies
rounds you remember feel fresh and
modern the most noticeable change
especially in the heat of the moment is
the enhanced audio the horrible death
rattle of a gun down zombie in the
unearthly howling of the hellhounds are
grading in the best way the guttural
snarls behind you feel more urgent and
that translates to greater tension even
on maps you played to death the first
time around
years old strategies need a bit of
tweaking thanks to the introduction of
black ops 3 zombies features which
further help in keeping the classic maps
from feeling stale gobblegum and its
various perks for example are optional
but depending on what you get you might
play a map much differently compared to
the way you remember that variety also
works for newer players especially ones
who started with black ops 3 and helps
to modernize maps for people who don't
have the nostalgic coming into this
collection chronicles also introduces
black ops 3 weapons but they make very
little difference in how you strategize
they're really just there to keep the
collection in line with tray arks latest
it is nice to pick up the kuda early on
if you spent any time at all with black
ops 3 multiplayer and want something a
bit more familiar until you can get to
the mystery box but you'll still end up
crossing your fingers and hoping for the
Raygun anyway of course that ray gun is
as satisfying to fire as ever
Zombies chronicles takes a good
combination of maps and upgrades them
with great attention to detail
newer zombies features keep the
collection modern but its greatest
strength is in the lighting and audio
upgrades so to make the zombies
experience that many fans obsessed over
before you'll creepier more tense and
more exhilarating than ever more amble
to keep my vodka safe with
[Applause]
easy